thirteen hours is directed by Michael
Bay and is inspired by the true story of
some soldiers who took a stand in
Benghazi when they had no idea what was
going on they had unclear orders and
they were there trying to protect this
American base under incredible duress
from an enemy that was overwhelming them
but really quick please stay tuned for
the end of this video because I want to
tell you about something really cool I'm
doing with loot crate this month and I'm
excited to tell you about the
sponsorship that I'm running with them
13 hours for me is a movie that I really
wasn't sure what to expect I went into
this movie I was like it's January which
is kind of like the cinematic wasteland
of the year and it's directed by Michael
Bay and it's being released with little
to no fanfare which is very rare for a
film directed by Michael Bay having seen
the film I can say that Michael Bay has
made his most mature movie since ever
this is the third time Michael Bay has
attempted to reenact a true story he did
it once with Pearl Harbor he did it
again with pain and gain I personally
did not like either of those movies he
has a hard time striking a balance
between fun entertainment for everyone
and actually telling a true story and
honoring that story with 13 hours I
think for the very first time he's
actually found that balance there's tons
of things that you would expect in a
movie like this there's a lot of
explosions there is slow motion and low
angle shots of people walking around and
the high saturated colors you expect all
of those things in a Michael Bay movie
what I appreciate about this movie is
that it really does honor and respect
its subjects these men who were fighting
for these peoples survival in their own
survival one thing this movie will
probably be criticized a lot for is that
it doesn't attempt ever to involve
itself in the politics of the situation
the motivation of the attackers of this
base completely unclear we don't
understand what's going on
politics are rarely ever discussed in
this film and for some people that might
be a problem for me I don't think it is
and I'll tell you why I think Michael
Bay is trying to make us the audience
feel as if we are these soldiers in this
moment because in this singular moment
of these soldiers lives the worst night
of their entire life they don't
understand what's going
on either their unclear as to what's
happening they're just trying to survive
in a hellish terrible situation so I
think the screenwriter and BAE made the
wise choice there to really limit our
information because the information that
the men involved with the situation got
was also extremely limited this is not a
perfect movie it's not a great movie it
is a better film than most Michael Bay
films and it's definitely a better film
than most January films my issues with
this movie are its first hour for one
I'm gonna be honest I almost fell asleep
it's rough it's a lot of character
setting up and it's all just the same
standard stuff you've seen guy has a
baby at home wife's pregnant as soon as
the battle starts the movie is
relentless until its conclusion but that
first hour was tough and as I said the
film develops these characters in the
most standard ways you could possibly
expect so you never really grow to be
attached to these characters you respect
the story and you respect what's being
depicted so I personally didn't feel
like I had a connection with these
characters which was disappointing
because the film is trying so hard to
make you care there's a lot of shakiness
at times the little too shaky it's not
overdone though but it's definitely
there especially in that first hour
there were a lot of parts where I was
like okay that's a lot of shaky and
cutting oh boy and that's not an
exaggeration I did that quite often
because the film just cuts a lot and
it's very shaky but surprisingly enough
in the long run I think Bay was actually
able to create a movie that does honor
the men and women who were involved in
this conflict as well as not making it
so overblown with Michael Bay isms to
the point where the film just deflates
and you're watching a movie that is
clearly fake the movie does feel fairly
authentic and for that reason I'm gonna
give 13 hours of be - it's Michael Bay's
best movie in a long time in between
this and the forest January so far
hasn't been that bad strangely so guys
as I said earlier loot crate thank you
very much them for sponsoring my videos
they are doing a new crate that I'm very
excited about because I love science
fiction it includes a lot of items from
the x-files as well as alien lots of
really cool stuff The Fifth Element
space invaders it
the invasion crate and it's going to be
sent out to people who enjoy opening a
cool box of awesome sci-fi goodies if
you guys go to loot crate comm slash
Chris Stockman and use the coupon code
Chris when you check out you can get 10%
off a new subscription you have until
January 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific Standard
Time to subscribe thank you a loot crate
once again I hope you guys check that
out I'm excited to get that crate myself
you guys are the best thank you so much
for watching if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck Munoz